ai vai voltar a todos como bairro
jardins chama antonio tem 22 anos e
estou aqui hoje uma razão muito simples
que é ter tal doença neuromuscular
degenerativa que chama atrofia muscular
espinhal q3 ele sabe vamos começar a
contar minha história estava dizer que
ao contrário dos meus colegas horas de
hoje ele não fez nada de criar uma vida
e nunca tive uma ideia por 43 anos e
além disso há já algum tempo e confiado
que minhas inquietações as minhas
alegrias dos meus problemas de fundo são
muito próximos de uma parte das pessoas
e portanto nos próximos do maior parte
de voz problemas tudo todos nós aqui
presentes e portanto não sei se terei
que enfrentar grandes coisas e trazer
grandes novidades ainda não é causada
por uma alteração no gene responsável
pela produção de uma proteína em sua vez
é responsável pela surpresa dos
neurônios motores sua vez são
responsáveis pelo crescimento e
manutenção dos músicos veja amanhã
complexidade do nosso corpo é eu tenho
15 anos quando foi diagnosticada a
doença e não andam bem como é que age na
altura esta descoberta do segundo tempo
passei muito tempo sem acreditar
comportamento que minha mãe celeste e
durante muito tempo de pensar um caso
quando perguntavam como é chamada a
minha doença e até há menos tempo ainda
não sabe explicar o que aquela minha
doença ao certo nova costuma dizer isso
o melhor é perguntar ao meu pai quem é
que sabe que essas coisas eu também não
gosto das forças muito claras quando
perguntam como é ruim a minha doença que
também encolheram os ombros fazendo
assim as mãos e dizer que não é muito
bem apesar de confiar a vida da minha
querida doença não tem passado ao lado
por acaso nem poderia ser muito
contraída por ser muito fora só por ser
muito otimista
o que se passava na cabeça na ocupada
contra o problema pra mim mais
importante quero não poder concretizar o
projeto o projeto minha casa minha vida
com 14 anos sente um privilegiado
estava apaixonado uma cidade calma
ocupar o tempo eu queria eu queria ter
para sempre que ele se locomove vida
quero montar a cavalo e sentem um
projeto do qual é o planejamento dessa
dessa desligado e além de tudo o que os
fazia estava com vivido aqui mas todas
as coisas que deixamos fazem já
conseguia já conseguia ver mais ou menos
como é que ia ser a minha vida que
queria fazer o que eu ia fazer prova de
vida e estava com a cidade morena
conciliar trabalho e além disso e
principalmente uma uma grande segurança
para viver mas como já disse há 15 anos
acabou se fosse um privilégio acabou
essa segurança para viver e acho que
estão querendo problema das paixões é
que nos fazem sonhar muito e quando e
quando acaba o e quando acaba um
estilingue automaticamente também morre
e não fica em xeque a capacidade sem
carregar o caminhão seja sem capacidade
da luz para frente e conseguimos ver
alguma coisa o que é preciso fazer acho
eu é reinventarmos mas isso custa muito
e e as pessoas são capazes do futebol
são capazes de fazer indiretamente
outras precisam muito tempo e outras
precisariam mais tempo do que a vida do
que a vida do planeta e agora mesmo a
implementar a pensar é para o power.com
tenta falar com esta coisa beterraba na
outra o projeto sony tenta tenta passar
o tempo
não estou a falar de sofrimento dos
outros eu sou eu expliquei o que é
negado ao passado não fiz um gosto com
conversando e não sou de certa forma
inventado continua montado a cavalo
companhia estudar até ter algumas notas
e quando chegou a altura de pauiní
cidade é que eu percebi que tinha tinha
que tinha errado com os oito anos 53
cursos do espaço de dois meses anunciar
em economia sem saber bem porquê e agora
todo mês trata também da agonia também
sem nenhuma razão especial para isso o
que eu tenho vindo a descobrir é que
nossa lances mal assim
e isso é uma coisa que a gente aprende
com o tempo é que nós não precisamos
estar muito focados no futuro porque a
vida toma algum sentido
o gosto pelo menos o meu voto não sei
como é que é
é como aquele filme portinhas comem
dormem em casa dos pais fazem carinho
que dá na cabeça e por fim um tempo sem
ninguém sabe bem como é que isso
aconteceu acabam por desenvolver algum
talento e até fazer coisas incessante
às vezes o bahia pode ter me ajudar aqui
foi proposto explicar como é que
enquanto ela salva vida e eudes foco não
sabia nada fácil ver como é que fica
encontrou salva vidas mas depois teve um
caso a pensar sobre o conceito do sal da
vida ea única coisa que vem à cabeça é o
amor e quando pensei amor
lembrando algumas pessoas e essas duas
por acaso são a minha família e os meus
amigos e e ea polícia não conseguiu
responder que não tem resposta para esta
pergunta como reencontrar o sal da vida
porque eu nunca me dei conta ter perdido
salvo o que aconteceu ainda acontece às
vezes e acho que vai continuar
acontecendo por causa da água é o
primeiro vamos tentar salvar a vida mas
isso é uma prática de soninha não é
propriamente uma falta de matéria prima
na maior propósito a propósito disto o
piloto de um anúncio em uma senhora
dilma que ela faz barragem é um idiota
na liga aí lembrei quando quando não
estava pensando que queria dizer aqui e
assim eu dizia fugirá vem dentro é uma
coisa também tenha aprendido é que esta
senhora tem uma certa razão nunca e
nunca com um lance de muito bem em um
conceito horas penso que algumas pessoas
é uma pessoa muito querida não tenha
transmitido que é o de conseguir a
sociedade ou fazer tudo que você feliz
o principal objetivo da vida é ser feliz
eu acho que o principal objetivo da vida
é vivê la a fugir a nado e infelicidade
ou seja a ausência de felicidade são os
combustíveis às vezes um treinamento a
nossa predisposição para a vida e que
diferencia a forma como vivemos
qualquer país posicionando pênis só de
nós próprios na nossa vontade depende de
algumas situações que no chão e
interiores ou até pode
entender uma situação especial mas
também disse não pensar assim que a
perspectiva de prostituição com fim de
cada um com que encaramos cada momento
faz toda a diferença na forma como
vivemos este momento e é também isto não
é nunca vim a compreender porque é como
é que as pessoas
contudo aparentemente tem uma grande
dívida e que não conseguem ter e outras
e outras que são autênticos princípios
com vidas aparentemente aprendendo
difícil não só de maneira nenhuma falar
de doenças conseguem viver da maneira
mais digna e feliz claro que nós
conhecemos outra pergunta também
colocaram foi como ultrapassar uma
doença degenerativa
eu sou completamente grand acerca da
doença ea cerca dez diretivas então não
sei de nada mas expõe que já existam
aqui estão algumas doenças de tipo algum
tratamento ou até alguma ruptura
a menina aí e contá lo e na outra passo
eu faço paz com ela continue a passar
até que descobre uma forma de curar ou
até que o próprio com qualquer pessoa
que nesta sala perfil no paço pontos
sentiu o que se pode fazer é passar na
linha de frente
eu posso viver como um casal apaixonado
h véu havendo muita atenção e carinho
posso viver como um casal à beira do
divórcio em constante luta com a ofender
mutuamente e a maltratar uns ou então
posso tentar chegar lá tentar que ela
não se lembra muito nunca ter muita
cabeça e investir viver mais livremente
possível tentar aplicar essa técnica
pois uma pessoa cheia de sorte porque
vivo de pessoas extraordinárias e muito
amor e faz até que não sinta muitas
vezes a necessidade de ter com ela
quer dizer logo no princípio da época
acrescentando e ea mesmo guardado por
causa de um pouco para dizer é no que
respeita este assunto das alegrias das
inquietações dos problemas na minha
opinião somos todos iguais
eu que não consegui fazer é subir
escadas correr agora não conseguiu
contato faz sozinho ea na grandes
distâncias mas não são necessariamente
mais infeliz com os outros por causa
disso existe problemas cento e sabe isso
na minha opinião é tudo uma questão de
adaptação do amor e do carinho loucura é
uma pergunta falta de esperança e saber
que os problemas são muito maiores
vistos ao longe do ideal perto
obrigado foi um prazer uma honra estar
aqui convosco agora chega
o jogo
olha quem se condenada pode dizer se
envolver